yeah that's a really good question I I
was talking in much too I was talking
like a philosopher and abstract a sort
of eternal istic language and so forth
um so I really do think that it is
belongs to the idea of liberal democracy
that people what I call equal voice that
people be allowed to say what they wish
and give what reasons they wish within
the constraints of morality of civility
and so forth but there will be times in
places your question reminds me of this
land of course there will be times and
places in which that ideal cannot be and
should not be fully realized now the
truth is that there isn't any so so if
equal voice is part of the idea of
liberal democracy then what it has to be
said is that the united states that i
took the united states and awfully
awfully long time to come anywhere close
to that ideal originally was only male
property owners who could vote well then
black said it as i recall a three-fifths
vote right their vote would count as
three-fifths of that of a white person
and women were not allowed to vote and
so forth on and on so it took us an
awfully long time to come anywhere close
to this ideal of equal voice so any any
society has to ask itself the question
how close can we should we come to that
ideal and the Turks in the 1920s out of
Turkey has followers maybe well maybe
almost certainly made the right decision
about that now it seems to me when the
French 200 years 200-plus years after
the French Revolution are still trying
to police religious talk in public that
strikes me as crazy France is not going
to come crashing down there for you know
but there will be times in place you see
the point it's it's it functions as an
ideal and one has to ask how we
accommodated the idea with affirmative
action you can't really justify
affirmative action in terms of just the
idea of liberal democracy but we thought
that there were reasons for for having
some good